each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available um this session uh is called
functional programming in the wild so we
have a great session with some great
speakers uh um and Don Sim is going to
go up first followed by Manuel tral he's
going to talk about some parallel H work
and Antonio sisino um following up
behind talking about some applications
and using FSH um for various science and
engineering applications and also in
computer science teaching so um I'd love
to introduce Don Sim here uh so I work
with Don I'm kenri teeder in the uh
Microsoft research connections team um
and I'm based in the lab in Cambridge UK
um and I have the pleasure of working
with Don Sim uh who's uh one of our
principal researchers um in the uh
programming uh principles and tools
group and he has um uh in his past um
for instance um architected net generics
which some of you may be familiar with
in C uh and also uh the person behind F
and so today he's going to talk about
some of the latest developments in fshp
um and so don sign
am I on great thanks everyone for for
coming I uh I didn't get time to update
my slides to this bright and white so
we're going to the dark deep dark colors
of of that I usually use um so I want to
talk today about I want to give you a
taste for what I think is the
um one of perhaps one of the most
radical things going on in certainly in
strongly typed programming languages
which is about which is what we're doing
with f 3.0 for
integrating massive data
sources directly into the into the
language and as we've been and this is
coming out in product form you can go to
the inv visual studio
2012 I'll actually be demonstrating its
use uh across platform today uh using my
Mac here as
well uh
and as as we've been finishing up the
product version of this work it's sort
of uh from practice to Theory kind of
thinking uh which is what I approach I
like to take just do something radical
and Powerful from a product standpoint
and also then go and consider well what
are the ramifications for strongly typed
programming and programming languages in
general where does this lead what
research opportunities does it open up
uh in in in the future and this uh talk
is going to touch both on the practice
in terms of you know the product and the
the the language and the data and then
also the the themes about reconsidering
strongly typed programming uh for the
modern information Rich
world first of all one of the great
things I love about F uh from the
Microsoft perspective is that it's open
source uh we we very much Embrace
working with the
open source Community to do interesting
things from from the the code base we
don't do development in an open source
model we do open source code drops that
as we finish up the productization of a
version of Visual Studio we then go and
have a chat with the lawyers and have a
chat with the Microsoft management and
just go through with the clearance
process which we're going through for f
3.0 the F 3.0 open source is in
preparation right now but you can go to
GitHub uh F Community open source
community on GitHub and uh take a look
at the thef open source code there it's
about under Apache 2.0 license you can
compile it up on Mac Linux Windows uh
you can also host the compiler in the
browser uh
in uh in in by compiling it as a as a
silver light component uh as you'll see
today you can get free open source ID
tooling for fop with mono develop mono
develop is a lovely little uh IDE uh
which runs again on Mac Linux or Windows
and I'll be showing the use of that in
uh just a moment okay I want to start
off with a quick retrospective on what
programming languages research and its
impact some some of the work on
programming languages and its impact on
on Microsoft over the last 10 years so a
bit of a uh uh a Time Warp from uh when
I when I uh in a
sense started my academic career uh it
started my research career in
1992 when I came to research in
1998 uh Microsoft research we started
off by doing net generics which went
into C generics the yellow things are
the various papers and specifications
that have come out of this work as well
as the actual you know million million
plus programmers using C today all of
whom are using this work which came to
directly from Microsoft
research
uh then we progressed on to sort of do
the F core language here uh in uh F 2.0
separate not part of my work but sort of
based on the the generics work uh and I
was tangentially sort of watching from
the sidelines of C link which is its
wonderful use of metap programming again
to tackle data integration into the C
and other net
languages uh we then did some work on F
meta programming we did some work on
cleaning up some parts of the basic
functional programming model to make
sure that patent matching was extensible
in the same way that everything else is
extensible in functional programming
languages uh we did some work on putting
units of measure checking into F uh
which um is a uh just just a fantastic
addition to the type type system to give
effectively strong typing for for for
numeric data uh throughout the the
language
uh if you want to use the unit
annotations and then we did some work on
Parallel programming for asynchronous
programming in F uh and then that has
been progressed I mean in a very direct
line of work into a version of that work
for C asynchronous programming just
coming out in 5.0 and we see from I
think very this work has been very
influential in you're starting to see
C++ and other languages picking up on
asynchronous programming as well okay
the common theme here is all of these
things are in some way or another
related to the strongly typed functional
programming research agenda uh which has
a long research history behind this work
and this is just one manifestation of it
across in the sort of Academia to
Industry kind of
divide uh so I'd like to summarize it
like this the back in 1998 it was all
objects objects objects and everything
had to be a class you had to use
inheritance for absolutely everything we
then through went through a sort of a
slightly strange manifestation of that
in aspect oriented programming and all
sorts of other fads running around and
anyway that's fine the dark days the
terribly dark days of that of
1998 uh where everything was objects and
absolutely nothing else in your
programming model but classes and
inheritance those uh and and very weak
type systems those days are behind us we
have mix object orent functional
programming languages being industry
standard we see lambdas in C++ of all
places uh just recently for good reasons
too we see JavaScript very functional uh
not strongly tip but very functional
programming language and its approach
functional first uh programming language
scalar and F of course as well being uh
industry manifestations of of um of of
of functional programming and uh
Microsoft and Microsoft research have I
think really played a strong role in
this transformation a lot of other
people have too but I think um we've
played played a pretty important part
okay so let's talk about 3.0 so the the
concept behind F 3.0 is is in some ways
very very simple which is that the world
is it's no no uh argument these days
that the world is massively digitally
information Rich uh you can see that in
this s of graph this is one done by
Kenji here which um is uh I I I I was
pretty amazed when I saw this this is
the number of open web-based apis that
are listed on the site programmable
web.com okay which is uh all about the
web as a programming platform and you
can just see the absolutely exponential
rise here in the number of open apis
that are available for use and we
wouldn't expect this trend to stop
anytime
soon okay but there's a very strong
sense in which our our programming
languages are information sparse okay I
sometimes use uh the the the you know in
many ways excellent language Lang
standard ml as an example of this in
that it's it's I mean it's a great
language it's not it's it's also in
sense a product of uh its times in in
that the the the the back of the
language contains an index of Library
functions that are built into the
language and that that Library function
is like read character and write
character or something and that is the
full sort of information based on which
the language is is constructed okay as
as an official sort of mathematical
specification that's fine from a
mathematical specification point of view
but you get the sense that that that
doesn't match the reality of information
in the world around us okay that all the
world all the world's information that
you're accessing it from the outside has
to be piped in through those two
Primitives that that doesn't seem sort
of right in some way okay so programming
language your information Spar you can't
you go to the the the net libraries or
the Java libraries and you can't find
the definition of a football player or a
chemical element or a
um or or or or a genome or a gene or any
any any real information apart from sort
of generic information adapters like XML
or uh or strings or streams of bytes or
some other generic things you would find
there so this is a big problem it's
especially a big problem for strongly
typed languages because these strongly
typed languages like f and Scala and
others are wonderful information
processing environments once you have
the information in a strongly typed form
but if you have to pay all your cost to
get that information into a strongly
type form uh through paing and you know
sort of some sort of serialization
Frameworks whatever else then you're
going to lose whatever whatever
productivity gain you pick up with the
language you're going to lose in the in
the around the fringes especially as the
world becomes more information rich
you're going to and your programs have
to interact with the digital world
around you more and more then you're
going to pay more and more of a tax at
the boundary it's fine if all you're
doing is writing Fibonacci or other
self-contained mathematical algorithms
that don't talk to the outside world but
if you need if your programs have to
interact with this enormous information
spaces around us then we have to change
what we're doing so fop 3.0 is is one
manifestation of starting to fix this uh
and I'm going to demonstrate that and
talk about these themes in information
Rich programming it's a interesting
thing about like well what Paradigm are
we really in F definitely comes from the
statically typed tradition but you'll
probably be surprised at the amount of
dynamically typed programming you can do
in language statically typed languages
like F and
C uh so the world has also sort of
changed so if this was the world in 1980
or 1990 where these worlds were kind of
being kept very separate in sense
programming has grown an awful lot and
uh as as it's growing things have sort
of merged uh in between and uh we let me
just turn those
off
okay uh uh as things have merged we
there's a bit of a search on for how to
make statically type languages more
dynamic in how to make dynamically type
languages more static for instance by
adding type inference which allows you
to give good tooling support uh perhaps
give approximate errors or Warnings
within dynamically typed languages so
languages like
um uh Dart from Google lie in in in this
kind of space uh the C and F actually
have a lot in this kind of space and
Java as well there's many ways in which
you can do Dynamic techniques in those
langu
and there's some interesting ways the
fop type Riders is really about saying
okay we're going to give up some some
things in static typing in order to gain
a lot in terms of information access so
moderating static typing in limited
ways okay so a little bit about F itself
this is our kind of Mantra for f
productive support of the interoperable
functional language to write simple code
to solve complex problems that was our
kind of mission statement for F
2.0 uh that side hasn't come out very
well but anyway oh you can see some FSH
code over the side it's a little bit
gray but anyway you see it it's this
standard functional functional
programming kind of code it's all
strongly typed because you get type
inference from uh over on the left and
there's some corresponding C code uh
which just gives you the difference in
sort of succinctness of the of the
coding Paradigm if you're doing list and
Tuple and function
programming uh it's just one example of
the comparison Point um there right it
gets used a lot uh in in in practice for
real industry things here's a a quote
from uh someone working for a power
company in the UK where they have a
calculation engine that helps to balance
the uh whether the power stations get
turned on or off based on various Market
signals that come into the system and he
uh he gives some description of why F
was a nice fit for this problem but we
often see F being used at for the code
at the the heart of a uh of an
application there may be a lot of other
code in C or other languages or what
whatever Java or anything JavaScript uh
around that but with some F at its at
its
core uh okay I'll skip this part of the
language taster this is just some
examples of object-oriented programming
here and some little bit explaining that
f is an indentation aware language like
python so you have to align those things
up like
that okay uh we in F 3.0 we add a notion
of query to the F language the the idea
is that the bit in curly braces is the
logic that gets executed on the server
okay so if this if this Netflix thing
here represents a data connection to the
Netflix service then you can write a
query to access that service and the
filters and so on will be sent as a meta
program to the query in whatever form
that that gets accepted and so this is
uh link queries in in
F okay so let's talk about F 3.0 so uh
let's um switch over machines here we're
going to do this bit on the Mac uh so
PC3 here we go okay pop this away
okay so here we have mono develop uh I
I'm going to display some data on the
right so I've I've squeezed the screen a
little bit here uh mono develop is yeah
as I said open source freely available
IDE for um uh you can use on Mac and and
Linux it supports F code to to get F 2.0
with mono develop you just have to go to
the addin manager go to the gallery and
install the f language binding there uh
and on the Mac mono comes with f so you
just have to install mono which is often
well on the Mac I guess it's not
installed so you install mono and you
install the F language binding and off
you go
okay
um so to give you a feel for f 2.0
scripting here let's uh let's
first load this
Library here okay this was something
I okay great so this um little Library
just creates a window here oh so what
have we got here we've got an F script
so everything I'm going to be showing
today is f scripting okay so the model
here is you have a reppel interactive
session down below uh and you can use
that to evaluate data so we can just do
um we can say take the numbers from 0 to
99 here and we can just highlight that
code and we hit alt um Alt Enter and
that evaluates and prints out the
results in the the window down below now
personally I prefer to show results over
in that window over there uh the one the
reason I do that is because you can show
graphical objects in that window because
I'm working on the Mac we haven't yet uh
lit up this show script which is only
like 10 10 lines of code or so to to
display graphical objects so everything
I'm going to be displaying on the right
is text but when we go back to Windows
and visual studio you'll see that we can
uh we can draw Graphics there as well
pictures and the like uh okay so we yes
we can take uh show on the numbers from
0 to 99 and hit Alt Enter and that
displays the the data over the right we
can extend that a little bit for X in
0299 generate x and x *
X okay and we can do a bit of functional
abstraction the cube of X is an
integer x *
X do that and then generate the table of
Cubes
here there we have the cubes over on the
right
okay great uh okay now
um but okay let's just look at a couple
of other things first of all yes we can
print um
oops you can
print hang on
Sorry's get rid of this I
accidentally pressed build then we just
ignore that
okay okay you can print out down in the
console below uh we've done that bit
already let's create ourselves a form
dynamically
uh we have that form there we can add uh
use functions as callbacks to add for
instance to the mouse click event a call
back which uses a a different print
function which says prints out some data
as part of it so as I now click on the
form over here you can see the results
coming out down below uh for for the re
reactions to the
form
okay okay let's get rid of this
okay but what we want to do is talk
about fop 3.0 everything you've seen so
far is FOP 2.0 uh and what I've done is
uh the fop
Community uh over the actually recently
have been updating the mono develop
support to also support F
3.0 and uh I took the a copy of f 3 a
pre-release of f 3.0 and and put it it
onto the the mac and and and and and got
it so that would work with mono develop
here I ask question here how does this
mono ID compare with the studio ID in
terms of running this uh it's very
similar as far as the F programming
experience is is concerned yeah yeah
yeah it's set up in pretty pretty we
we'll switch back to visual studio in a
moment you can get a feeling for how
they how they
compare okay uh right so F 3.0 the thing
we've done with f 3.0 is to open the
language so that we're using a a
provider model for libraries for the
language okay and this is stop and think
about this for a moment okay so instead
of referencing normally when we have a
library in a programming language we're
used to a library containing a fixed set
of types and functions okay that's what
a library is okay maybe it contains at
the most 100 or a thousand types and
maybe for each of those have 10 or five
10 20 kind of functions associated with
them instead what we're going to do is
make that into a provider model instead
of having a fixed set of libraries to
represent the stuff we can access we're
going to have an ond demand or lazily
computed type space which you can
program against okay so it's it's a very
simple idea of just instead of having a
fixed Library we're going to use the
provider model for libraries okay
and what I'm about to show you is one
example of using that provider model to
take an information space in this
information Rich world that we have
around us and making it available in the
programming language uh
directly and the information space I'm
going to work on is called free base so
let's just take a look at this
information space
here okay that's free base okay so it's
uh ontology if you
like uh it's got lots and lots and lots
of data okay it's in a pretty organized
kind of form you can see you've got
films 40,000 updates to films last week
1 million
locations 10 million entries under the
music domain okay there's a lot of
information here wouldn't it be nice if
we could program with this information
okay wouldn't it be nice if this Source
was just available to us in the
programming language okay so by using
the type provider feature of f 3.0 we
can do exactly that with this one
reference to a type provider which is
only about say a thousand lines of code
we're going to project in that entire
ontology both the schema and the and the
uh metadata into our programming
experience okay so we reference a type
provider we then create a data context
to uh access the data store and now we
start to explore the schema okay so what
you're seeing here is dynamically
drawing our types from the web ontology
okay so as I press dot it goes and talks
to that web ontology to bring in the
types into the type system
okay how do you get the L how do we how
do you get the L the library the dll is
a type provider yeah that is that is the
component that is the adapter component
okay so the website has to provide no
someone has to write someone has to
write a dll which deals with a protocol
that is being used to talk there's a
particular so we have a type provider
for SQL databases we have a type
provider for the OD data protocol for
example Freebase uses its own protocol
so if if a if a if a if a data service
has its own bespoke protocol then you
have to write a type provider for that
okay but there're also very generic
protocols like XML we have a you can do
a type provider for XML data in general
okay okay so we're accessing uh um
freeas here and let's take a look what's
in here uh we can go to science and
technology for example you can see
there's quite a under here okay we have
all the different fields of science
represented and you can go to astronomy
for
example and you start to see collections
of objects appearing okay so this thing
here under asteroids represents all the
asteroids in that ontology
okay uh and you can you can go through
through through through the list okay
okay now because we're doing not
just uh not just dynamic programming
here we're doing we strongly typed
programming then as a programmer works
with this data they can get strongly
typed hints about what the data is and
what they what they can do with it for
instance it gives us these summaries
here of what of what's in the asteroids
table
okay okay so usually we uh we go to the
chemistry and biology domains here first
of all uh so let's take our show window
here and for instance um imagine our
task is
to uh is to get the names of the amino
acids okay so there they are we can show
the amino acids and they come up over on
the the
right or uh similarly with the chemical
elements and starting with these data
sets we use it's a very usual process of
working with data where you might for
instance detect effect some uh in the
chemical element set two names here
don't have an atomic number listed so as
we're writing this code and we're
working with the elements here we have
some chemical element X then we can do
completion and because we're working a
strongly typed setting then the
environment can know all the different
properties of that are available for the
chemical elements okay so as we look
through here for instance look at the
atomic radius of the element then we can
see that uh it has an atomic radius here
and not only that but the radius here us
using the units of measure feature in F
the radius has been converted into a
value in meters okay it normalizes into
the SI unit system as the values come
into the programming
environment
okay so let's
um
come through with these so we'll at the
end here finish up with our little
display of the periodic table in order
with the atomic weights of the most
common isotope of each of the elements
coming down here on the right and now
what I want you to imagine is how that
that data is Trivial to discover in this
environment if I ask any of you to sit
down with this environment to start with
data Dot and to go and find the names of
all the asteroid
in the or go and find the names of all
the chemical elements or their
properties like the boiling point of the
of the data you could do it it's
absolutely trivial and imagine how would
you do that programmatically in any
other programming language that doesn't
have the ability to embed an ontology of
this size into the programming language
environment
okay okay okay so we think of that as
language integrated web data it's one
example of using the typ provider
mechanism back in Visual Studio well
over in Visual Studio which is a pretty
similar programming environment I'm
going to show you a second use of the
type provider
mechanism
okay so in this case the type provider
we're referencing is for the World Bank
okay the World Bank is a major provider
of data it's very interesting data from
a computer science perspective because
it's about big metadata and not big data
the data sets themselves are actually
small like the time series data for
indicators that are provided by the
countries uh them themselves so in the
data you can see the countries and
because we're working live with the
database it can provide us with the uh
the strong the the the the intellisense
list for all the different countries
that are available we can choose a
country and we can take a look what
indicators are available from the the
data store and there are thousands and
thousands and thousands of these you can
look down the list here
okay and for instance you can search for
word like debt or you can if you're
interested in in health statistics you
can look at say malnutrition in uh third
world countries and you can see those
the the different data sets that are
available for for use so we can for
instance take a set of the countries
here evaluate
that and what I'm going to do here is
pull together a chart of
we can go to the indicators and we can
search for the statistics to do with
population here and we'll take the
population total
here and we're going to uh just make a
chart of the how those populations of
the different countries on the right
have grown over time based on that data
drawn from the world world
bank and then we might do some
usual normalization of that data and uh
test whether that's normalizing
correctly and then normalize that from a
starting point of one in 1960 and you
can see how the different countries have
the different growth population growth
rates
yeah it's it's Unique to there's some
similar uh there's the idea finds
expression in the go through language in
the Java uh in the Java environment uh
which is sort of I mean I won it's kind
of an Enterprise language where they in
in business this is an incredibly Val
feature not only for open web data but
for businesses as well you can imagine
you're sitting in a in an Enterprise
what you really want from a programming
perspective is to have all the
information in the Enterprise that
you're allowed to access at your
fingertips in this kind of way okay so
the the information Rich programming
really has a strong tradition in the
Enterprise kind of world okay uh and so
yeah that's what that's what is driving
that go Su language which is an
interesting language I'm sure we'll find
expression in other languages over time
as well so that's a function
of World Bank who only provide this kind
of data for language no no the World
Bank provide a service okay so just like
we saw that um so World Bank provide an
API API all of this is making web
requests ultimately making rest web
requests to like you'll probably see one
example here this one here uh which if
it comes up oh great okay uh
uh oh yeah hang on uh let's
try one more one more
try okay that that kind of data you you
make a web request and it gives you data
back that's what's happening under the
hood but you can imagine how hard that
would be to program with okay because
you'd be getting these XML blobs back
you'd be lost in just a sea of mess of
data okay it's about taking all that
away and projecting it into into the
type system and programming it with it
as if it's to type data
okay okay so okay uh okay I'm not going
to have time to show this where it's
about F uh
data yeah
um I well ki's encouraging me to show
this uh but uh I actually don't really
even have the demo actually well let's
let's let's try and show it okay just
fig CH it uh let's see if this this
works up it comes
up
okay
so the one of the the major things we've
been working
on let's see if this comes up yeah this
isn't gonna not going to work hry okay
one of the major things we've been
working on is using this type provider
mechanism to access Hadoop And Hive data
okay so you want to be able to point the
type provider at the at a machine such
as this open F machine which is an a
machine on the Microsoft local network
and do exactly what we did before get a
data context for that machine and be
able to do strongly typed programming
against the data on that machine
including querying that machine and
sending the queries to the Hadoop
cluster from uh from from from this
point and that's something you'll be
hearing a lot more about as we as we
start to roll out this work over the
next over the next six
months okay so type is just like a
library uh it's an adapter between data
services and the F or net type system
you can kind of think of it as um on a
form of on demand type macros uh but it
is unique to
F so the language itself doesn't contain
any data it's an open architecture for
data adapters right into the heart of
the programming experience and and you
can write your own type
provider
okay so to finish in the last five
minutes I want to capture some themes in
information Rich
programming so the problem is that
languages don't integrate data and if
they do it's in way high friction ways
like XML libraries for languages okay so
or they use code generation okay but
code generation doesn't scale to the to
the scale of schema that we're beginning
to see available on the on the web okay
or in even in the Enterprise today you
know you to try and generate facades for
this these kind of data sources is just
not uh you could do it to a certain
degree it's this industry standard way
of working with this stuff but it's it's
it doesn't scale the tooling can be bad
uh the strong typing uh where you might
get strong typing if you use code
generation but uh if you don't use code
generation you use lowest common
denominator techniques like XML and
that's got a whole lot of problems in
itself so from a computer science
perspective I think I like to go back
and look at a very basic equation of a
basic relation of type of programming
languages this is where the programs are
so historically there's just been a huge
amount emphasis on you know new object
models you know are about modifying this
part of the world okay working on E okay
uh so type systems and Analysis and
verification are often about working on
the towel there but I think there's one
big fellow who's been actually forgotten
in all this work okay which is gamma
okay you know what is how do
we extract the structure that is in
gamma and of course what we're doing
with type providers is pushing
Expressions into the gamma okay to allow
us to draw out the latent the latent
structure that's available in that
environment but when you go back to many
computer science analysis papers okay
they start with this equation that the
environment at the start of the analysis
is empty okay okay and uh for me this is
the one of the biggest lies ever told in
computer science right it is like it's
like saying our world around us doesn't
exist it's a complete denial of reality
around us it's a denial of the fact that
programs have to interact with that
reality and this you know I sometimes
like to to think of type providers as
being the cult of gamma not okay it's
about saying that gamma not is real the
programs have to interact with it and we
have to make that the massive
information richness that's available in
our Digital World available to our
programmers and not hide away from it
and pretend that it's not there
anyway that's all meant to be a bit
tongue and- cheek but I hope you get
what I
mean okay so uh themes Big Data it's not
just about big data and Hadoop and uh
and the like it's about big metadata as
well uh uh strongly typed languages and
tooling surely have to have a role in
taming this uh this world of big
metadata we moderate strong typing a
little bit uh if schemas change then you
get problems but uh often these schemas
are very stable so huge information
spaces have to be can and should be
viewed as software components we have to
start when we think about schema change
we have to think about that in the same
language and terminology we think about
component versioning and there can
actually be a healthy interplay between
this kind of uh thinking about these
things uh I think one of the key things
about F Type providers is you can do
multiple data standards with one simple
mechanism okay Rich type systems
importing Rich metadata data where it
exists uh programming languages it's
about this gamma thing how seriously
does the programming language take gamma
okay are languages effective at working
with external information spaces do they
have queries Json XML type providers dot
dot dot this should be one of our key
measures of programming
languages and uh I think we have to make
sure we get a Synergy between this world
of Programming type systems and
information space
metadata and uh see the role of the type
system as being about representing that
those information
spaces uh and so you can see things like
you know uh propagating units of measure
information or propagating security
information from the outside world in
through the type provider uh Provence
and many other things rankings and so on
that you could start to propagate across
this kind of boundary which leads to
these kind of research
questions uh uh can we design type
systems which incorporate schema change
policies you know you might imagine a
type system which says this is going to
type check but it only guarantees to
type check for the next year because the
type sources that you're using come with
a policy that says their schemer is only
guaranteed to be stable for the next
year okay so those sort of things those
sort of questions start to enter into
the equation and there's some other
examples of the kind of uh uh if the if
the metadata for instance is
probabilistic and uncertain then can we
use that usefully in the programming
language
context okay okay so to summarize the
world is information rich and our
programming needs to be information Rich
too it's big data to Big
metadata uh and information richness I
think for me anyway has changed how we
think about strongly typed programming
languages without giving a without
giving up on using strong typing but
just changing the perspective of what
strong typing is and what the role it
can play in in taming taming that gamma
in that equation okay thank you very
much and I hope you've enjoyed the talk
and we'll move on now to to
Manel thanks Don that's great I think we
could probably take like one question
while manell setting up so uh does
anyone have a question
yeah uh how does f compare with o camel
how does f compare with keml uh so the
the core language of f is very much
inspired by EML uh and you can there's
even a small subset that will
cross-compile between the two uh I think
since that sort of f
1.0 uh kind of subset then the they the
language F has sort of progressed in a
in in directions which support it the
role of the language so we've added
object-oriented programming which in
some ways is some similarity
syntactically with the Cel mechanism but
we has an object mechanism that matches
the net object system and so in that way
it's got more similarities structurally
with Scala for example as a
language uh the other comparison points
might be um I I I mean in terms of the
actual FSH programming experience and
it's very much you know in terms of um
say you're a programing off a thousand
line component in F uh then it's got lot
in common with oaml they're trying to
keep that that goodness of that core ml
programming experience as a way of
solving problems and expressing the
expressing the solutions particularly to
to to problems that involve moving
structural data around so there are lot
there are similarities in the core
programming productivity experience
between the two languages but um f is
gone as in in some other directions in
terms of like information richness or
object Ed programming
yeah uh just one question yeah I think
Manuel's Now set up so thanks a lot Don
so over to to Manuel who's come over
from University of New South Wales and
he's going to talk about parallel hcll
and this is a project um which MSR
supports and it's working with a number
of people including Simon Payton Jones
another person in the Cambridge lab um
so over to Mana thank you hello
everybody
um
oh can you hear me now yeah
excellent so I only thought about
setting up the computer not
myself okay hell hello everybody um as
kentley already explained I'm going to
talk give you overview about data power
programming uh using the function
language hcll and that is a joint work
with uh a number of people at the
University of news house Wells so
Gabriel Kel Shan Lee Roman linski Ben
liip my and Trevor McDonald and also
with Simon pton Jones from Microsoft
research Cambridge
so it's all about parallelism but
parallelism has been changing very much
in recent years yes so uh it used to be
all about special Hardware very
expensive computers and and and all
about getting the latest every bit of
performance out of those but um today um
everybody got Pearl Hardware every PC
every laptop every tablet every
smartphone has multicore CPUs and
multicord gpus so um how can we program
them our goal is to provide and a simple
way to um uh write parallel programs
where the emphasis is of course on
performance because why would you write
a parallel program or why would you want
to use parallel Hardware if you're not
interested in the potential performance
increase but where the overriding goal
is really
productivity uh as it's usually in
application programming as opposed to
systems programming and the way we go
about this is to provide a what some
people call a semi-automatic way to uh
uh parallel programming meaning
obviously we can't take any random
sequential program and hope to make it
in some magic automatic way into a par
program but given the programmer
supplies us with a good parl program a
par algorithm then um we provide
compiler technology to translate that um
such that the application program
doesn't have to deal with the messiness
of explicit concurrency that's that's
the idea so here you're talking about
terrorism within different code of the
same uh across are you talking about
across different CPU so I'm talking
about one program running at the same
time on multiple CPUs or multiple CES uh
of a single CPU or on a GPU so let me
give you some uh just an idea of the
type of applications we've been looking
at so we've been looking at Graphics
applications uh like R tracing and um so
we've got this
uh little demo here so just running on
One Core you see bit slow right the
frame rate is not good
enough but um if we um use all four
cores in this laptop then uh you get a
nice smooth animation okay so that's one
type of application so
Graphics
um
uh another type of applications um uh
come out of computer vision so this is
an application doing Edge detection in
fact it does a real time Edge detection
so um again if I go um and start this
program then um the program is
unfortunately
on my desktop uh over here but I can
bring it over so it uses the webcam in
this computer and you see there is a
picture of myself and um uh an edge
detection running on that uh on that
image um as we are speaking and yeah you
can change various par parameters but
that also utilizes uh all four cores
which you've got in in this this
computer um and as a third third example
um we've been uh yeah before we get go
to the third example let me tell you a
little bit about the performance because
traditionally people are a little bit
concerned when people when somebody
talks about functional programming and
Par programming then the concern is that
maybe these functional programs are
quite slow and then maybe you can
polarize them but on an absolute scale
it doesn't really help you a lot but
that's not the case anymore that might
have been the case 10 years ago so in in
this example of this Edge detection
algorithm we are comparing our code
against a library called open CV open CV
is an open source computer vision
Library which uh as far as I understand
is quite well optimized and it uses ssse
instructions to speed up computations
even more and it's the dotted lines but
it's not parallel so independent on the
number of threats it's always the same
speed whereas um the solid line is the
hle program and um you see if there's
enough parallelism so the um the image
is big enough with eight cores we break
about even with this uh C library so why
is H slower here well we don't use um s
instructions uh currently the Glasco hco
compiler uh well the development version
uh supports s instructions but the
version we used for those bench marks
doesn't um otherwise we would cross over
probably here so you see we're getting
the same ballpark and we can effectively
utilize uh the parm and moreover um we
can run the whole thing on a TPU so the
blue curve is the hesal program running
on multicore CPU and the green uh curve
is running on a uh GPU specifically an
Nvidia Tesla that's
um two generations back uh but at the
time it was a quite powerful GPU yeah so
what your xais number of CPU threats
yeah so the x-axis is the number of um
CPU threads whereas the GPU we always
utilize the whole GPU using 10 thousands
of threads otherwise a GPU is is very
very slow so the green line is really
the whole GPU and uh the xaxis only uh
considers threats on the CPU um so you
see the GPU performance um is quite good
but sometimes um for some applications
you can get much more performance out of
a GPU than a CPU so in this case some of
that edge detection the last two phases
are actually fairly sequential algorithm
so the GPU program actually uses a mix
of GPU and CPU code but that limits the
amount of scalability you can the amount
of of Paralis you can get out of that
application uh due to the algorithmic
properties okay as as a third
application we've been looking at
physical simulations so here for example
at a fluid flow simulation in fact it's
uh the fluid flow algorithm of uh CH
stem which um uh is quite well known in
the graphics Community as far as I know
and um we can run this as well
what happens here um I can put a smoke
or a fluid into an area and then apply a
velocity and uh we get this particle
simulation U again that runs on on all
four cores on this uh
computer and um again I've got some
performance figures so if you compare
that to that that um uh
method was published in a z graph paper
and that paper comes with an optimized C
implementation and the horizontal do
line which is our reference
implementation is the original C code
which hasn't been written by us so it's
really a well optimized c not just for
comparison purposes and the um solid
line again is the H program and here you
see this Sol solid line repa minus N1 is
on one threat so
um actually depending on Matrix size the
hle program is already faster than the C
program that may come as a surprise to
some people so recent improvements in
code generation for function languages
have gotten us to a point where we can
actually um generate quite efficient
code and then once we use
Paralis um the we are even faster so
again we can run this on the GPU and
here the GPU outperforms the CPU by
quite a bit because uh this algorithm
can be mapped completely onto the CPU
and there's no CPU component we've also
looked at Medical Imaging um uh so here
it's an interpolation of an MRI image um
and there we we don't have any
comparison to C code because this um was
implemented actually by some other
people using our system uh who found the
algorithm was so complex that there
rather Implement in a high level
language like hll than um doing it in C
code okay so how does this all work so
there are really three key ingredients
to our work and one is that the first
one is that we control effects we limit
side effects instead of controlling
concurrency which is the traditional way
of doing it in an imperative language
the second one um is that we use types
to help uh the programmer Express
knowledge about the behavior of the
program that they want to achieve about
the operational Behavior to express that
in a declarative manner in the program
and and that information is then
utilized by the compiler to generate uh
that highly efficient code and uh we are
working in data par
framework so um let's start with uh side
effects so this is just a small example
of a hll program um hll program that we
have a function an argument in hll you
don't use brackets around AR arguments
that confuses people in the beginning
and uh on the right side we have the
function body and on top uh is a type
signature type AR consisting out of type
arguments and type result now as a h
programmer you know there's no effect in
this code why because the type is just a
normal type not saying anything about
effects so because it's pure we now we
could these two sub Expressions here for
sorting and Computing maximum could well
be executed in parallel there cannot be
any race condition or anything um
semantically that's guaranteed by the
programming language so how do we know
that because in h we track effects using
types um that's just the type of normal
integer but once we prefix it with IO or
there's some other um effect prefixes if
you like as as well uh we know there
might be an effect and then the result
is an in again but there's an effect as
well and so if our original example is a
pure function whereas a function reading
from a file obviously is not pure it
it's got an effect and and that
difference also appears in the way we
program the bodies of the
Cod
so that that's the first uh important
thing that that we know we can paralyze
all these Expressions now the second
component is uh that we use types to
guide the execution of the program so in
particular we use types to distinguish
between the parts of the program which
should be executed sequentially and
those which might be executed in par so
um we have this data type of arrays
where uh which has two par uh three
arguments uh specifying concrete
representation of the array the shape
which is the
dimensionality and um the elements
stored in that arror so let me just say
a little bit about these
representations um which we use to index
uh the aray data type um there can be
all kinds of representations so on one
hand we can have a normal unboxed array
which is like a c style array but some
computations uh we want to fuse with
other computations we want to merge
multiple Loops into uh single traverses
and then we can indicate in the type
that we want a delayed array which is
just a functional representation a
representation of an array as a
function and the shapes and element
types there there are nothing special so
then operations operating on these
arrays uh look like this the types look
like that we've got a function here
binary function uh taking two arguments
and two arrays with that same element
types
and um that just applies this function
element wise to uh all the elements in
the array producing a delayed array so
we can fuse that into other operations
or more complicated function is a
stencil computation for implementing
convolutions which we used for example
in this fluid flow example and then we
can get quite sophisticated type
description this PS5 here and I don't
ask you to uh read this in detail but it
is a description a type description of a
partitioning of an array into the core
array and for boundaries which is the
type of De composition you need for
efficient stencil
computations um so how does the code
look like we don't have time for
complicated example so let me just give
this simple one um here we compute a DOT
product by using the CIS function
multiplying all elements pairwise and
then summing them up and we get type
which tells us that this works for uh
any numbers uh which we can store in
these
ARS so let me just skip that um how do
the GPU computations work we currently
we are not at the point where we can
take exactly the same code and run it on
a CPU or TPU but they're very similar
the difference is that we use embedded
computations for for gpus so gpus have
um uh acquired a few uh restrictions in
the way you have to program if it should
be efficient um one is that you need to
be careful about uh doing everything in
a really synchronous uh fashion and the
other restriction is that you have to be
careful with memory access pattern so uh
that data access is um efficient um and
we achieved that by embedding uh
computation language into uh into the
main host language and and in this way
we can restrict the uh form of control
flow which we allow in this embedded
language um so that we get these limited
control structures and then we use a
generative approach um for those people
who've been in the talk about power
programming um this is quite similar to
the python
say uh cting uh example which with with
say they discussed um we use a
generative approach to generate this
highly tuned
code okay and the main difference here
is really in the type again namely that
the result is an accelerate computation
a suspended computation but then the
actual code looks the same and the by
the type the compiler knows that this is
an embedded computation and we can uh
treat it to uh to a TPU okay so um how
do we do on time um 10 minutes okay so
um the um third uh point that I like to
address is um that we are focing
focusing on this data par programming
model which is well known to work for
certain range of applications but there
in in traditional data programming has
uh some shortcomings um we traditional
data power programming I mean the models
which are used in standard languages
like foron are the Cuda um language for
GPU programming and this same model
really underlies the type of programming
I've um um describ so far but what's the
limitation let's get back to the dot
product we may want to use the dot
product as a component in something
bigger so this something bigger here is
a function which takes a sparse Matrix
um and a vector and multiplies the two
so it's a sparse Vector matrix
multiplication now here I used another
language feature this is called an array
comprehension you can read it like a set
or List comprehension uh it says for
every sparse Vector in the sparse Matrix
do what's whatever is on the left hand
side namely compute the dot product
between this second argument and that
sparse vector and uh then sum up all the
elements in the dot product so that's
exactly Matrix Vector
multiplication
but these error comprehension supposed
to be executed in parallel but the sum
well the some we arguably we might also
want to execute in parallel but then we
have a parallel computation in a parall
computation so that's nested parallelism
um that's okay maybe we can have a
special sum M mented some to do that but
what about P maybe p is defined in
library so does that already contain any
parallelism we don't
know so it may include nested
parallelism um in traditionally in in
traditional uh data par languages well
you have to rewrite your program you
basically as a programmer you have to
inline the do product or you have to
know how it's implemented in the library
to be sure uh that that you don't get
arbitrary
nalism and that of course kills
modularity so how can we get around this
problem well one way of tackling this
problem um is to to go to so-called
nested dataism where data operations can
be arbitarily
nested and another benefit of moving
from Flat to nested data prism is that
you get a handle on working with Spar
and irregular structures such as trees
or hierarchical decompositions of space
such as you for example would use in an
in body algorithm in a in a hierarchical
um algorithm like the barns heart
algorithm to solve the end body problem
uh in fact you can um if if you allow
arbitary Nest dynamically determined
nesting depth you can quite conveniently
Implement uh General divide and conquer
algorithms in in a nicely the
traditional functional way and and run
them
Pro and um luckily there are program
Transformations and um uh going back to
the seminal work of guy blell uh on on
the Nestle programming language um but
which we extended in in many ways such
that uh this program transformation can
now be applied to fully fledged
languages such as hll um and um in that
way get a handle on this modularity
problem and at the same time are able to
work with much richer data structures
with data structures really functional
programmers are very much used to be
able to work to like trees uh and and
would be disappointed if they can't do
that in a in a pearl setting but the
compiler technology here is is quite a
bit more involved so it's still quite uh
experimental but it is part of the H
compiler so we get overall we get the f
ing picture um on on one hand we uh by
going from Flat to Nest dataism we gain
a lot of expressiveness although things
get harder to compile on the other hand
um by going from plal purpose CPUs to
gpus to more restricted Hardware um one
way we can can uh realize that is uh by
moving from a full host language which
is compiled to an embedded language
which which uh we do uh runtime code
generation for
so but at the end of the day I think the
main message uh out of all this work is
types are really very very important we
use types to distinguish effectful from
non effectful code we use types to
describe the difference between array
representations delayed arrays
decomposed arrays for stencil
computations and many more array repres
presentations uh we use types to
identifi distinguish between embedded
code and host code where we can uh TP
the embedded code and we use types um uh
this program transformation which we use
to implement nestate parallelism is also
heavily based on types it's it's in fact
Guided by types so that's the important
part here's a summary um and thank you
very much for your
attention
thank you very much Ruel that's great
that's great so um we've got time for a
question or two while Antonio gets set
up so
um anyone got yeah oh two
question um I see what's hackage hackage
is um a package uh a library data by for
hle it's like um python uh or Pearl has
C pan the package repository uh where
you can get all kinds of pear libraries
this is the same thing for hll it's a uh
uh heish uh does.org is is the one place
where you get all hll add-on software to
your haale
compiler um so if I want to use a
functional language for scientific
programming should I use hcll or
FP I haven't tried doing any scientific
programming in so you would ask I think
defer your judgment
to half an hour that as well and then we
can have a maybe we can revisit that
question after this next talk that's
fantastic so perfect segue into
Antonio's talk so thanks a lot Manuel
and um over to Antonio sanino who's um
from the University of
Pisa um should exactly exactly yeah
exactly so and we have for function
interfaces so you can
always so Antonio um is one of s of
leading members of the F uh Community
he's written with with Don um expert F
and that's just being updated for f
3.0 um and Antonio also teaches F to
both computer science and non-computer
scientists so over to Antonio thank you
keni so uh what I want to share you with
with you today is an experience that now
it's something like three or four years
is going on in Piza uh uh in teaching
computer science to non computer
scientists especially uh people from
science and engineering and uh sharing
with you some thoughts about uh the
results we got so far and uh if F SHP
which is a full-fledged language can be
useful to teach to non-computer
scientists and I found a lot of
interesting uh things uh uh in in doing
this activity I do it uh I did it in in
many ways in several projects so I will
show you also the results of these
projects and uh where everything started
up uh for years ago so uh the real point
about programming is that uh in the
beginning they were just machine
programming and if physic uh people in
physics was uh uh you know using Punch
Cards and do a lot of computation and it
was really about programming knowing the
machine and then and then machine was
not anymore real the big problem and uh
there were algarin we we we were in need
a lot of algarin uh and in teaching and
even doing experimentation it was the
focus to develop new algor nowadays uh
there has been a major shift and most of
the people programming is in in in the
truth is doing uh software coordination
I mean they tend to pick up algorithms
and put them together in many ways so uh
it's uh it's a a lot of time since the I
wrote my last while loop or uh whatever
I tend to to to say for each something
do this and that and call this library
and put the result in this that library
and the algorithm has been has become so
uh complicated and so focused on
specific areas uh to the point in which
which is difficult that someone from
outside is able to contribute on on that
space so usually you end up to Google
somewhere and look for some algens that
fits your
problem and and this this has been for a
problem for scientists because
scientists Were Us it to build up their
own experiments from scratch they still
do it uh sometimes for instance a large
hydron coll they did it but uh it's
difficult to grasp all the complexity
uh the it uh infrastructure are as bring
into the game and and so actually it's
quite challenging to to figure out what
does it really means to teach
programming to computer to scientists
and non-computing scientists because of
this because actually they don't really
care about all the bits we have just to
to have our computer run which is
something interesting because uh when I
was young I make a mouse and this is
from
uh and they they told me on Mickey Mouse
that basic would have been uh my
programming language I mean that that
was in the 80s in the 80s basic was
incomod was the the way to talk to the
machine but nowadays nowadays things
have changed a lot and uh actually uh
math lab and Excel uh have found the
most useful tool they use in uh science
and engineering and there are several
reasons for this uh the first one is
that scientists want to and Engineers
want to be in control of their own
computations and they tend to hate quite
a lot to have to interact with computer
scientists so actually there is an
impedence mismatch on that space and
that's uh mostly because they tend to uh
feel that they lose control over their
own algor and thinking and the other
thing is that uh the science develop and
program development has become something
like uh you you it takes time but the a
scientist needs a more much more high
frequency Loop ju just to check and
validate hypothesis and run code and so
uh they started using Excel in the
biological uh World they use it a lot
and math lab a lot especially in
engineering uh they also use Dynamic
languages is python um little bit less
JavaScript they Ed a lot Pearl uh for
text
processing and and many many others they
uh still use C C++ Fortran code but they
really decreasing in numbers because
actually uh you really usually uh the
the cost to to to maintain the code is
much higher than having a python or
something other different Library so
things have really changed for
them and at some point you may wonder
why why this uh this shift in the in in
the in the Panorama and uh my answer has
been that uh software and computers are
not anymore made for scientists by
scientists and Engineers so in the
beginning computers were built to to
perform computation by scientists
themselves nowadays scientists are
military did uh also uh use the tools
developed for for our as a people not
for for for
scientists uh as a as a tool for
computation so the main purpose purpose
of having a computer or a GPU that has
been uh shown in the previous talk is
mostly for gaming and as an accident it
turns out that you can do matrices for
some other computation but it's really
an accident the main goal was to have
fun for kids so uh in in this Panorama
it has been uh really really difficult
for scientists to find the right way to
develop their own code and Matt laab and
Excel have become their their friend in
in in in this path but it has some
drawback uh
in uh in this u space I will discuss in
a little bit so uh
F when uh when uh I I uh found uh found
out about f i was thrilled because uh
uh first of all it was a functional
programming language running on net I
always uh uh thought that functional
programming is a fairly natural way to
do many things in computer science but
the truth is that it never made it
through a commercial product or Library
so it was rather frustrating to to be a
functional programming uh without the
libraries and the ability to interact
with technology so uh first my my first
impression was wow now I can uh finally
and eventually uh the have my Graphics
running on F on F rather than C than C
and get the benefits of both words I can
get all the libraries and I get the
flexibility uh of the functional
programming world uh because it's a net
language it inter interoperates very
well we did and I will show you machine
so we did we we built things and
controlled them through F code uh there
is type inference which is a good thing
because it gives to the language a
flavor which is resembles like python or
a dynamic
language and uh uh you can interactively
evaluate expression which is a beautiful
thing so actually don't already showed
this and it's beautiful because you can
even uh load and interact with C code
and do regressions tests for instance so
it's a good thing not just in the space
of coding and debugging your own program
but just uh testing or learn to use a
library interactively which is something
I do quite often uh it's
efficient which is a good Pro because
usually
especially you say efficient how does it
compare with you WR
uh that's a tough question because it's
more uh about net uh versus uh uh C++
rather than F versus C++ comp down to uh
it it it f compiles down to Intermediate
Language msil and then gets just in time
compiled uh into machine language and
executed so usually uh you can have 1.6
one two uh as
in the average I think I think the usual
terminology people use is okay if if C++
gets 100 score of 100 okay high
performance languages are in the 98 to
100% C plus plus okay efficient
languages are in
the uh 80 to 98 range okay Dynamic
languages are in like 10 range okay so
the real comparison point is like
Java they all take the same approach as
F which is to get the 80 out of 100 for
performance okay and I think I think
that there's a there's a reason why
Antonio isn't using the word high
performance view because doesn't necess
always land 98 out of 100 you can use
high performance C++ libraries for
math that that that's that's an actual
recommendation do not do your math
code
yeah that's that that was the other
point it's rather easy to uh hook into
whatever Library you want and call
native code even with Special Assembly
structions in s
so and uh but it feels like Python and
something that cames up is that people
is looking for high level language even
in computer games they're doing they uh
looking for high level language because
actually you have to to write down a lot
of code and the cost of the bug and C++
so high so that the typical model is to
use coordination language as it is for
instance in the unity uh game engine
which is fairly popular nowadays which
uses mono as a game a coordination
language and the C++ code is us it for
rendering 3D models and physics and
everything so uh and and it feels really
like python or Matlab and so uh my first
experience with the uh student
integration and said oh this is very
much like mathlab I mean I can write
down an expression evaluate look at the
result and decide what I want to do and
then try again which is uh very much
like the workflow you you you find in
this kind of tools and so I thought that
that could have been interesting for for
them because one of the big question
scientists nowadays have is how to share
the results actually math lab can be uh
a problem because you need math lab to
to run the results you you obtain uh you
you have constraints on the hardware you
can access because it should be mlab
compliant uh so uh I thought that uh it
was programming languages were mature
enough to at least in part to cover uh
the Matlab story of course Matlab has a
lot of high performance algorithms and
everything and very good mathematics and
if you need it badly you should use lab
but in many everyday uh scientific job
uh I I thought that F was just fine so I
I I decided to try this this approach so
uh that was uh four years ago and I
developed the Tool uh which is called
vslab which is an Adan for visual studio
that sort of complement this experience
you have in visual studio and allows you
to have dockable windows inside Visual
Studio to to have a Graphic
visualization not just text inside the
visual studio just to uh give you uh an
an idea of what it
is uh I have
just few lines here so it's an open
source project it's available on on clex
so this
is one of the first thing I I I saw
running on
uh on F it's a 3D function viewer made
by Dawn and uh actually this is a
dockable to Windows so I can
dock the graph I can grab it and this is
uh direct Tex so this is full 3d and the
nice thing is
actually I can change the function
interactively with which is something I
want to do if I'm a scientist so
convinced by this example I said okay
let's try to and go into the field and
convince uh people from other
disciplines to use this uh kind of
apparatus and let's see if it's possible
to to teach them uh to use this
thing and of course you can change
parameters and whatever I don't really
care
okay um
so this is vslab so
vslab uh triggered the project the first
one uh at chanto at University of
Pisa uh and I did a graduate course uh
to students in biomedical uh engineering
so it was uh so far from computer
science as you can imagine and it was
interesting as a course because uh uh
they had some class on C code because
in they uh course of study uh there is
still someone engineering that say they
have to St study C code because it's the
right way to do programs uh and they
were interested in what in imaging in uh
uh in controlling hardware and in many
of these areas the sea is simply not
satisfactory I mean uh people tend to
use uh in Hardware control yes
especially they use a lot of Arduino and
B is C based but on the visualization
part they tend to use Matlab and they
tend to abuse of Matlab because they
badly need data structure but actually
Matlab tend to convince people that
everything is a matrix so uh they use
they do all sort of tricks to represent
graphs inide matrices with very Weare
results and
um so the the go my my personal goal was
okay let's try interactive evaluation if
it works for them uh if uh they really
use easily uh device and eventually they
can chip their own code which is a pro
for them a lot and the result has been
this one so I have two pre-loaded
videos so this is a a microfab
fabrication machine which is what I call
a
jet cell jet printer I mean they exree a
polymer uh on a surface to make cell
grow on a surface and reconstruct
tissues so this is an example of the
machine uh running uh
sorry let's try
to
No it's it's
dark uh sorry about that anyway there is
a needle that uh is controlled uh
through the F by F uh control and this
is uh the interface that has been
developed by an engineer so this
interface with the help of a computer
scientist which is another Pro uh so
actually the the biomedical engineer
developed most of the C code uh to all
these buttons on the drawing surface and
at some point code sort of grown up and
uh she wasable to to manage this
complexity so I found a undergraduate
student uh that helped her and they
shared a language so the the computer
science student help helped her a lot in
re refactoring the code and having the
code running in a in a proper way but
she was still in control of their own
code so the project was uh fairly
successful and uh uh it has been uh it
led to a p PhD and uh so they they used
us to build 3D uh cell structures uh
something like bones or stuff like
that
so after that I I did that course
several times and I have uh many other
experience to show uh
to uh to this to present but we have no
time uh this year I I I did another uh
experiment with a class at schola normal
Superior which is a well famous college
uh in Pisa uh to the class of science
class of science uh as inside
mathematicians physics uh uh geology
chemistry and so the class was very
heterogeneous with a very different
background and uh I continued this way
uh I I started with fshp uh and teaching
of doing uh my teaching Interactive l so
I tend to open visual studio type in
code and discuss with them the code and
then send them the fragments so that
they can uh test
this and I can show you I
think I
have this is the typical thing uh this
is the first lecture of the course and
what is interesting is that is uh I
found a way to discuss uh uh the topics
which is rather counterintuitive for
computer scientists but which has shown
to fit very well the mindset of a
scientist which is not really curious to
know what's under the hood and so it's
very well uh ready to accept things such
as this is a type measure so they can uh
look at that it's a type measure is a a
feature so that you can label
uh numbers and you get the standard
calculus for measures so uh it's it fits
very natural and the uh the the roots in
ml programming language and in
mathematics usually uh help them to
understand what's going on I mean even
the lat construct is very well accepted
because usually they don't have any
background in C inspired uh languag so
the result has been uh rather
interesting because in in the second
lecture I was
able to show to discuss in detail with
them something like this which is take
an infinite sequence of numbers just
filter the prime numbers which is
something difficult in a sense but they
they did uh did essentially very well
with this so I was rather surprised on
this experiment
and just to show you that uh it's not
just uh I also just received the
feedback so this is uh the first student
uh we finished the course a few months
ago they working on a project as a final
exam and this is the first output from
the class it's from the
geology uh class which developed a
viewer of segy segy is a format
geologist use uh to uh store the data on
the acquisition campaign they do on uh
explosion under the Earth and they
measure uh the senal propagation and
this is a typical representation they
use in in in in their work and he's been
able to after 12 hours of course uh of
lectures he's been able to uh develop
this and that was sort of going to the
web web fetch for a segy uh library in C
that of course was there uh use it from
FP uh use the F chart library that uh
don shown us uh just before to to plot
the graph and that's the result so it
was fly impressed so actually his
problem right now is just to transpose
the graph and is getting what they us it
to pay for uh the a viewer for this
actually is rather expensive I found it
uh so that's interesting
so my uh experience has been quite good
but one may wonder if this is also good
in computer
science uh
so my experience is also uh in Piza we
we went back to uh ml teaching in the
first year uh for many reasons one of
these reason is
f uh was a driver of the decision
because F being put inside Visual Studio
was a uh a sign that functional
programming was taken as a assign that
functional programming was mature enough
for industry so from java we went back
to ml in the F ml uh ml is a
u rather old programming language which
is sort of uh uh the basis for f in a
sense it has been studied in the 70s and
it has been taught in many university
around the world uh as a functional
programming language and introduced many
notion that are still there in many
programming languages there been one of
the
roots and
um and then I personally use it in uh
user interface programming Course and
there is a very deep reason for this it
allows me to break down the UI
development while still using a
framework uh which is the the
framework that commercially available at
least on a Microsoft platform platform
but also uh G gtk sharp which is open
source and and I want to show you
an example of
this so this has been developed in
lecture I show you the the coded it's it
has been a lecture in this course so I
developed interactively the problem so
this
is it's a very
simple
uh
graphic control that shows bolts that
bounce and uh you can introduce a new
Bol
by drag and drop and uh and I was
developed with the intent of show to
show them how to develop a user control
in Windows forms which is something you
need to know uh if you want to do uh
graphical programming so just to get the
Paradigm behind this this uh kind of
programming and uh and a nice thing is
that uh they felt useful uh the
introduction of units of
measure uh they found it uh really
useful and so uh I show them pixels and
seconds so all the physics has been
expressed in pixel per second speed and
everything and I was impressed that then
their own assignment assignment uh were
written by using this and it wasn't
required me it was their own decision to
use them so it has been kept as a good
sign
uh so just before I run out of
time I want to show you the the reason
why I'm using F A Lot which is different
just for teaching uh and I want to show
you uh just to show this divide and full
of myself publicly uh so this is a
neuros sky uh headset that allows you to
essentially brain show the brain waves
so it's one point EEG that you can buy
for I think 150 bucks and um uh so you
can so this is very risky because you
know Bluetooth is faulty but I'm going
to try that you have to hard white your
ear to get the current going going
through your
skin and uh and I got this toy and uh
when I when I get a toy I run with the
iPhone application I got from from the
um from the vendor and uh uh second
thing I did I did okay I want to program
it I mean I'm interested in do for to
use it for doing something like uh I
don't know uh
and the problem was how to study what I
was uh saying and that that's what I I
did it I mean this is oh
again
okay so let's connect and hope
everything work
yeah and uh so there is a little bit of
very few lines of code so 90 90 lines of
code that
show Gohan there we go so let's dock
it here where is
it okay so this is
my uh these are my brain WS or at least
supposed to be uh I'm not sure so I'm
still studying them so there's no
evidence it is working but at least I'm
just plotting the data I'm receiving
from the serial port and uh and it's
quite nice because in 99 90 90 lines of
code have been able to uh do something I
mean get a feeling of the sensor get a
feeling of how the sensor Works
displayed the signal go to the computer
uh through Bluetooth and uh uh and a
library there is a protocol uh so you
you must know uh the format of the
packets uh emitted by
the uh and I was already working so
actually I was interested in uh
detecting the
uh the disappointment uh they say
psychologist they say it's possible to
to detect this appointment I was
interested to get feedback because they
say that this is uh can be notic it even
before it gets conscious so it's
interesting did I hear you say you had
to do something special in attaching it
to your ear no it's just because you get
a a current low voltage current yeah so
that's the ground have to hurt yourself
yeah so what's that device for
originally oh actually they use it for
uh uh find to do mind control actually I
saw a parro device we saw in the videos
in the keynote uh made fly uh flu with
the control of mind so there are these
two uh are uh surrogate so the the these
are the row datas these twool uh are the
attention and uh meditation signals so
uh these are
uh what the vendor says cap is capable
capturing the relaxation and uh and the
activity uh signal and using those is
possible to discriminate you have some
amount of voluntary control voluntary
control about on on them so you can and
write something that gets controlled by
the uh your head oh it's sort of scary
okay so I think it's time to wrap
up so uh I found that uh functional
programming it has been really well
accepted by uh scientists and Engineers
so uh we're discussing to sort of
consolidate this experience into
coures uh that are not any more
experiments and uh uh make them a lot of
productive so that's that's uh I think
the the real world word
uh
still uh I found that object oriented
programming is a barrier so when I show
them types and classes sort of it of
wall and they stop it to so sort of uh
they they they had a lot of problem to
get the idea of object orientation so I
found out that they can easily use uh
objects but it's difficult for them to
think in terms of objects and software
engineering so maybe after some time but
not now and uh and it's been a nice
language to share the experience and
also uh been a really good programming
language for uh computer science
scientist uh so if you have any question
let me
unwire